hi guys we are here in St Louis the
chess capital of the US and today we're
doing a match but it is not like other
matches we've done yeah we have a board
that has wobbly pieces this is supposed
to be an art piece but we're going to
use it for a competitive match
and it'll be interesting let's uh I've
never played outside with this board so
outside in the real world with the
wobbly pieces okay Eric this is going to
be the first game I beat you straight up
no odds good luck I'm playing three plus
two luck 32 yes going hit you with my
wobbly pawns my wobbly oops we have to
be gentle with these if anything that's
kind of a handicap for me oh no my
wobbles okay we got this I've been
preparing for this moment wow I don't
think I've seen that move before it is
breaking Edge modern Theory all right
we're going to play this okay maybe it's
not don't mess with my spinny p second
Jesus Christ look at that P wait it
wants to do things I don't think I was
supposed to take maybe a small maybe
start you know a third time no no we're
not restarting we're we're we're
finishing this game is this a famous
Eric Rosen trap I me it's it's an
opening slightly gone wrong now for a
white but Alex Ben told me we're always
supposed to take I wonder H there's
always exceptions though to I have trick
rules okay we don't have a lot of
options here we have one move which I'm
not very fond of bing bing bing this is
really not how this game was supposed to
go I like how none of the pieces are
wobbling yeah now we can just see my
very sad game
play I must have pushed E3
first yeah you forgot to play E3 in the
opening but it's playable that is kind
of a critical
mistake all right we're going to
challenge the
center oh your uh oh no my screen
recording he cheating cuz he knows
that's the only way you can win this
very crushing
game okay it's going to hit you with the
wobbly piece
Gambit somewhat
recovering maybe it's still equal
material so what do you think of my
opening after all those wait a second I
mean you're not like completely losing
yet what are you doing you're giving me
the bishop I don't even know if this is
a bishop this is a bishop that's a
bishop I think okay no we're fine we do
I don't think I'm giving it to you
though no yeah I thought we had
something the wobbly pieces thrown me
off if anything I'm giving you my pieces
so let's not do
that oh I got so confused that I thought
your Pawn was my pond cuz they kind of
blend in into the
wood yeah it's important to
differentiate between the the shades of
brown
okay now you're giving me a pawn I offer
oh yeah oh no my he doesn't know wait I
actually think I could take it you know
what I'm going to take
it this is how you you learn Life
Lessons by taking things that look free
I think this is okay I have a I have a
cckar rusi do you want to give the
cheari what are you coming
everything seems
defended but I honestly can't tell what
pieces are mine all right you want to
push that's okay could take your knight
then you take my Pawn what if we did
this
check maybe another
one king is about to fall off the board
but I think it's hang hang on
resign uh well not yet it's it's hanging
on don't like your he night coming in
and I jesus this is very
stressful okay we're going to
Flack he's attacking me you have plenty
of time 36 seconds mean that I think if
your king falls down it should be game
over I mean it's on like a what 20°
angle so it's still almost
upright I want to I want a bz Gambit
let's B Gambit think it would be only
fair after the handicap I gave you oh no
my queen okay it's still very
dangerous but we have increment all
right oh there is Inc my w pieces are
hanging on to each other isn't that kind
of nice it's very wholesome they made a
little team and they're Cheerleading
from the
side okay where's my
compensation the king's coming down oh
he's still he's still oh he's bringing
himself back to
life
actually don't know what to do here well
you did just give me a queen I did CU I
I was excited to play the bz gavit again
I mean it was a cool I would do that now
I don't think I want to take this wow
okay oh maybe I should have wow he's
coming in with the Rooks okay now I feel
the
compensation maybe I should have taken
all right the wind is blowing it's
getting more
difficult uh we don't have many
defending moves when in doubt follow the
wind all right we've got a lro and
attack
wow I mean I
see
Jesus this may have been the worst game
I have ever played no you're up a queen
it's it's all okay I think I don't think
so we going to check me or we're going
to run check me again I'm only
threatening one check and one Queen uh
and a queen There Goes My Queen all
right he's going to double now I have to
calculate so I don't want to lose my
Pawn
go okay now what to
do okay when inal push a PA that what
Yer taught
you pass pawns must be pushed my back
rank gonna have to fight you want to
bring in the bishop wow also have six
seconds you know could be better there
goes my
queen I think my Rook is more powerful
than your queen I just the Queen's kind
of lost power when it looks so
Derpy it's a very Derpy queen that you
have wait am I tripping or is your Rook
what is
happenes what we're all just tripping in
life can't I take your Rook is that just
if you want to you
can you have 5 Seconds to the
side oh that's a pawn p pawns tast all
right I realize this has to be the word
this is a I thought this was my okay I'm
telling you in the sun it looks like my
Pawn okay okay we need to do a time okay
that was I want a real game I'm getting
I genuinely thought this was my pawn and
then it Tri me when we see this position
it seems like white pawns should be here
not black Pawns on on camera they might
not even be able to tell